bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver à
la une de ça vous regarde ce soir
emmanuel macron hausse le ton contre ses
adversaires sur les retraites sans la
nommer le chef de l'état accuse la
france insoumise d'alimenter les
violences mais surtout de laisser penser
que le pays serait devenu une dictature
alors pourquoi le président est obligé
de rappeler que notre pays la france est
une démocratie comment en est on arrivé
là on en parle ce soir dans notre grand
débat la ferme neufs ont rebondi à
l'assemblée nationale après la parution
du livre de vanessa spring aura sur sa
relation soudan prises avec l'écrivain
lorsqu'elle avait 14 ans et bien
plusieurs députés de droite de gauche
veulent changer la loi sur le
consentement sexuel des mineurs
explications dans un instant avec nos
invités puis notre grand témoin ce soir
revient à la télévision après trois ans
et demi d'absence et elle revient sur
lcp avec une très belle collection à
d'entretien sur le thème de l'engagement
maïtena biraben est avec nous ce soir
voilà pour le programme c'est parti
hashtag cvr n'oubliez pas on y va
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
nos invités en plateau ce soir maitena
biraben bonsoir sur mer iom et bienvenue
sur lcp on est ravis de vous accueillir
sur la chaîne parlementaire dont vous
êtes l'un des nouveaux visages dimanche
soir prochain 23 heures on va vous
découvrir dans un exercice un peu
différent de ce que vous avez fait
auparavant cinq fois trente minutes de
tête à tête avec dans un décor très
épuré avec des personnalités que vous
avez choisi risque caroline fourest on
va les détailler un peu plus tard dans
l'émission on va parler aussi de votre
actualité de votre regard sur la
télévision mais on commence avec
l'actualité c'est cette nouvelle journée
de mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites le projet de loi il est
présenté aujourd'hui en conseil des
ministres donc le gouvernement avance la
rue insiste et le président de la
république a les nerfs un peu qui
s'échauffe avec une petite phrase qu'on
va commenter dans un dans un instant on
en parle avec vous natal yele masse
bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes député modem du val d'oise ma
nombre est bienvenue la députée
européenne la france insoumise et yves
thréard éditorialiste au figaro alors
que gilles a dit le président et bien
c'est stéphane blakowski qui va nous
l'expliqué en détail dans sa chronique
son billet si j'ai bien compris on
l'accueille tout de suite
[Musique]
bonsoir mesdames au soir dans sa chute
un bon soir rien alors si j'ai bien
compris ce soir vous avez un peu d vous
allez quand même l'objet de cette
réunion entre l avenir si j'ai bien
compris macro à ce matin un peu vide en
macro oui vous avez raison puisque la
familiarité comme ça avec le président
sous prétexte que contrôle aime bien ça
se trouve ainsi qu'il a dit je vais vous
le dire allez on va dire il a piqué un
petit coup de gueule est l'un des mâts
en fait qu'une partie de l'opposition
ont par la france à une dictature on
qu'il avoue 5 google pas comme à sainte
anne avec la sécurité israélienne mais
bien quand même on écoute aujourd'hui
s'est installé dans notre société et de
manière séditieuse par des discours
politique extraordinairement coupable
l'idée que nous ne serions plus dans une
démocratie qui est une forme de
dictature qui s'est installée mais aller
en dictature une dictature c'est un
régime
une personne ou un clan décident des
lois une dictature c'est un régime on ne
change pas les dirigeants jamais si la
france c'est cela essayez la dictature
et vous verrez alors bien sûr pas quand
le président ses nerfs garder le sourire
de mariée en main en brie part dans
l'opposition elle se réjouit donc ça
tombe bien ségolène royal vient de faire
son entrée dans nos positions donc pour
fêter ça elle s'est fait un petit
plaisir ce matin sur bfm tv
cela dit elle est pas la seule c'est
quand
même le régime autoritaire c'est le
terme combat à la fois jean luc
mélenchon mais aussi au marine le pen
les deux principaux opposants alors pour
justifier son accusation jean luc
mélenchon je vais mettre son interprète
on essaie d'être plus court que jean luc
mélenchon ça le jeu devrait y arriver
première raison au fait le fait que ma
qu'on soit très exposé et donc limite un
peu culte de la personnalité deuxième
raison la répression policière dans les
manifs non il n'est pas le seul à
dénoncer mais fait un argument pour lui
et enfin il estime que la justice est un
peu une instrumentalisé contre
l'opposition dont convoi il n'en a pas
il fait référence donc à l'issue de ces
trois points le diagnostic et bab là un
ta came quelque chose se passe en france
que je crois profondément malsain qui
était jusqu'à présent j'ai essayé de
peser mes mots et je fais attention
parce que vous savez comment il me plein
sur un mot nous avons parlé de dérive
autoritaire mais clairement un régime
autoritaire est en train de se mettre en
place donc voilà régimes autoritaires
marine un emploi même origine
autoritaire elle est le fait même pas
raison un peu pour se situer le dit
d'ailleurs la hongrie de lecteurs hors
ban est un pays beaucoup plus
démocratique que la france emmanuel
macron donc elle le dit ça dans la
presse on voit des dernières on est un
peu étonné c'est quand même au parlement
européen vous êtes élu voilà voté qu'on
a condamné la hongrie parce qu'il ya des
des dérives sur la justice sur la
liberté d'expression on hésite un peu de
mal à suivre là dessus non effectivement
c'est moi qu'on puisse dire emmanuel
macron et ses opposants n'ont évidemment
ou comprend pas la même définition vizir
la définition de la démocratie works et
quel est le pays démocratique pas
démocratiquement alors il ya un
classement adore les classements publiés
dans dix économistes donc un journal
libéral anglais donc suis pas sûr que ce
soit la source et la lecture préférée
demain en hongrie mais c'était un
journal à pirey celui des dessous voilà
même réputés fabrication de sérieux mais
alors qu'est-ce qu'il dit france comme
moi étaient pratiquement 167 pays et
sont classés donc non norvège 9,8 sur 10
167e corée du nord 1 sur 10 donc et la
france alors à la france elle n'est pas
un régime autoritaire son emplacement au
contraire il ya vingt-deux pays qui sont
considérés comme totalement démocratique
et la france elle est 20e donc on
pourrait faire mieux enfin il est quand
même largement dont la hongrie qui est
55e puis après il ya d'autres payer
encore plus loin non bon c'est bien sûr
la russie on sait que à la fois jean luc
mélenchon et marine le pen ont souvent
défendu un peu poutine son 134e la
russie donc c'est quand même très très
loin derrière et si on prend d'autres
modèles démocratiques quoi tu as parfois
cité mélenchon comme le venezuela 140
yens cuba sans carreaux la boîte à meuh
est sorti assez le progrès économique
donc on le lit jusqu'au bout forcément
est vraiment exagéré de considérer qu'on
serait dans une dérive autoritaire alors
voilà à partir de quel moment un propos
exagérés devient complètement fou
linguistique mais sur la crête mais en
même temps voyez moi ce qui m'inquiète
c'est que dès lors qu'on dit qu'en
france est une dictature bah ça veut
dire que contre une dictature
la violence de la violence devient
légitime donc dire la france n dictature
savez dit oui la violence on a droit
d'utiliser c'est ce qui inquiète le
président évidemment
au démocratique il ya une chose que je
ne peux pas accepter c'est la haine la
violence et du respect la haine la
violence et du respect on a le droit de
le faire dans une dictature nous nous
sommes dans une démocratie
nos dirigeants ne nous plaisent pas on
vote contre eux on en votes pour
d'autres alors juste pour conclure il ya
un sondage consiste parfois donc ce
piège de l'ifop on demande aux français
si on devait redresser la france qui est
un petit peu sur le déclin est-ce que
vous ne croyez pas qu'un pouvoir
autoritaire pourrait être une bonne
solution de la question est un peu long
comme ça mais adam 40% des français qui
disent oui dans certaines circonstances
un pouvoir autoritaire ça pourrait être
une bonne solution c'est quand même
l'inquiétude de voir que une partie des
français sont finalement pas si attaché
que ça démocratique n les ir d'autorité
d'homme fort aux cheveux ça veut dire
c'est assez classique que je pense que
personne ne me contredira ici dans les
périodes de crise on a envie que papa
nous donne un cadre et on a envie de
l'autorité c'est un réflexe qu'on a ça
veut pas dire pour autant que les cils
pas parce que les français ont envie
d'autorité dans un moment qui jugent un
peu fragile ce qu'il l'est qui sont
contre la démocratie en fait la
formulation exacte de la question faut
la lire elle est très longue mais dire
un pouvoir autoritaire quitte à faire
quelques concessions sur le post pour
les démocrates et les verts
stéphane ça vous gêne parce qu'il est
dit luc mélenchon la france régimes
autoritaires il ya eu des répètes mans
il ya des dérives autoritaires comment
vous appelez un pays dans lequel vous
avez une majorité de la population qui
s'expriment contre une réforme et que le
gouvernement passe en force comment vous
appelez un pays qui fait usage assez
largement de la violence policière à tel
point que les pratiques de violences
policières sont dénoncés par le cadre
des nations unies des ong comme amnesty
vous remarquez que j'ai pas dit qu'on
était dans une dépêche gym résulte est
ce qu'il est dit mais les dérives
autoritaires chose que de dénoncer tel
ou tel chrono les frères de parler de
régime et de dérives de dérive
autoritaire oui je persiste et signe il
y à des dérives autoritaires quand on a
un homme monarque républicain ou
monarque lui comme certes élu mais vous
savez la démocratie - la conception de
la démocratie que j'ai et c'est en fait
la la divergence elle vient de là la
conception des manuels macron la
démocratie c'est homélie et maintenant
vous vous taisez pendant cinq ans j'ai
tous les pouvoirs c'est le cas il a tous
les pouvoirs donc il peut faire ce qu'il
veut soit dit en passant il n'a pas été
en plus élu pour cette réforme des
retraites si on met même ça de côté il
n'y a pas la capacité ou la possibilité
de s'exprimer pour le peuple j'ai envie
de lui dire il dit il dit dans sa
fameuse phrase il dit la dilution il ya
des représentants il ya des négociations
pour salir et puissance est la même une
exception qui faisait la dictature moi
j'ai envie de dire emmanuel macron alors
qu'il laissait la démocratie et on
démocratie quand il ya une réforme aussi
importante de société je crois qu'on
sera tous d'accord pour dire c'est une
réforme importante de société alors en
démocratie un outil qui s'appelle le
référendum et qui peut permettre de
trancher ce genre de questions qui sont
quand même pas des petites questions
pour fêter dans son programme j'aurais
juste comprendre on est dans une encre
hassli lit le report de l'âge à quend
plage délai sera considérée la france et
elle démontre durée de cotisation bien
clair on reste une démocratie parce que
on entend quand même les classements et
un certain nombre de critères oui vous
le reconnaissez sommes nous sommes une
démocratie dans laquelle il y à des
dérives autoritaires ces dérives
autoritaires et chaîne à la fois de la
volonté du pouvoir à ne pas écouter le
peuple et à ne pas utiliser les outils
démocratiques qui permettent de
l'écouter le référentiel aussi des
outils de répression policière la taille
ce sont des dérives autoritaires quand
je pense qu'on peut qualifier comme ça
natal et les masques qu'est ce que vous
répondez à ces accusations de dérive
autoritaire dans le pays je réponds déjà
bien évidemment comme vous l'avez dit à
juste titre emmanuel macron a été
démocratiquement élu dans son programme
présidentiel le candidat macron qu'il
n'écoute plus personne pendant cinq ans
au et c'est effectivement de réformer
les retraites et c'est exactement ce
qu'il est en train de faire et il le
fait pas on le décide en tout seul je
vous rappelle quand même que depuis deux
ans il ya des discussions et des
négociations avaient la majorité
l'ensemble des syndicats n'ont pas la
majorité et alors vraiment la série tr
silva yaro présent et daniel barritt
démocratique à la sanction
ne vous a pas échappé que dans quelques
jours le projet a été présenté ce matin
en conseil des ministres il sera débattu
en commission à partir du 3 février et
puis dans l'hémicycle à partir du 17
donc on ne peut pas dire quand même que
ce ne soit que la volonté d'un homme
tout seul contre le ps que vous
reconnaissez que les tensions qui se
manifeste dans le pays à un climat une
atmosphère il peut y avoir une part de
responsabilité dans la gouvernance la
méthode à façon de faire absolument oui
jet ski je marche pas je le reconnais je
crois que nous n'avez pas nous n'avons
pas été bons dans la pédagogie dans la
présentation de ce projet on ajoute
encore qu en fait le peuple n'en est
prévu c'est ce qu'a dit manuel oui mais
c'est parce que moi je suis en train de
vous dire je n'ai pas très bien si vous
prenez vos distances par la pêche je ne
dis pas que le peuple est idiot et qui
en a dans la concentration des pouvoirs
ne comprend pas les jeux malmené les
corps intermédiaires
il ya beaucoup d'agitation quand même on
le voit avec ces manifestations qui
durent depuis le 5 décembre ce qu'il
faut quand même rappeler c'est que quand
le haut commissaire jean paul delevoye a
présenté son rapport
il y avait quand même plus de 60% des
français qui étaient favorables à ce
projet de réforme et puis il ya eu toute
cette agitation
et puis a eu aussi ces outils militants
vous savez ces fameux simulateur qui
sont construits sur la base de je ne
sais quoi très objectivement et je pense
qu'ils vont nous préparer c'est à dire
pas six mois après l'arrêt faute de quoi
les éléments viennent de sortir là dans
le dans l'étude d'impact vous n'aviez
pas la valeur du point il ya tellement
peu d'impact était calme au passage
d'être assimile va faire baisser
utiliser les finances est dédié aux
retraites ça c'est une chose qu'on a
appris aujourd'hui c'est quand même pas
rien il ya tout un débat sur le
pourcentage du pib dédiée au financement
des retraites à l'heure actuelle et les
deux capteurs forçant on apprend dans
l'étude d'impact qui va même baisser
autour de 13% alors qu'il va y avoir
plus de retraités donc mécaniquement si
la taille du gâteau à se partager plus
petites avant une question sur le sur le
chiffrage mais je voudrais qu'on reste
quand même sur les mots qui ont été
prononcés ou est-ce que c'est rare quand
même et les mots souvent leur président
de la région mais comme ça ils sont
souvent l'antichambre de la violence et
moi j'appelle chacune et chacun
responsables syndicaux responsables
politiques à faire ex vraiment attention
à ne pas agiter davantage les peurs elle
ne les effraie à quoi il joue le
président la caisse qu'ils essayent de
provoquer en disant ça aujourd'hui ça
donne quand même une caisse de résonance
à ses adversaires et n'a propos qui sont
assez à contrôler et je vois pas
pourquoi ils s'engagent sur ce débat
dictature alors que la france est
évidemment pas une dictature alors
qu'ils attendent autre chose à régler
qui sont de l'ordre de la vie
quotidienne des gens personne ne
pourrait admettre que la france est une
dictature que la france soit un pouvoir
fort je vais vous donner une réponse
structurelle une réponse conjoncturelle
la réponse structurelle c'est que la
france c'est pour ça qu'elle est classée
que 20e sur 22 démocratie dans le monde
parce que elle a un système
institutionnel très particulier unique
au monde où vous avez un homme autour de
qui tout tourne qui pourra être un jour
une femme on l'espère c'est le président
de la république dont près dans le le
charles de gaulle disait que c'était la
clé de voûte des institutions du régime
et c'est vrai que ya pas de
contre-pouvoirs face
institutionnels face au président de la
république le parlement je suis désolé
et a aucun pouvoir ou très peu vème
république un régime autoritaire en fait
c'est un régime qui a été écrit il
général
sortie pas à la sortie on oui quasiment
à la sortie puisque c'est on est au
début d'année à au milieu de la guerre
d'algérie en 58 et le charles de gaulle
et a appelé par un président socialiste
il faut le dire justement pour essayer
de régler ce problème algérien dans
lequel on est dans un bourbier total
j'ai pas fini pourquoi aussi le problème
et effort parce que les syndicats manon
aubry vient de dire quelque chose qui
est complètement faux tout à l'heure les
syndicats sont ne représentent personne
vous savez qui c'est les syndicats ces 8
% des salariés publics et privés
mélanger en france jamais
je rien j'ai dit que la majorité des
syndicats n'étaient contre la réforme ça
vous me l'accordé c'est la majorité
s'indigne représente horaire lui et pour
moi il représente ne représente pas
suffi lui % des salariés en france que
d'exprimer si l'on comparé je vous avais
parlé je vais je vais parler si vous
comparez les dix candidats il savait le
taux de syndicalisation ici quand même
au danemark c'est 70 5 75% la
représentante s'était pour sa part son
activité beaucoup pesé pour syndiquer
parce que c'est pas tout à fait même
syndicalisme mais les syndicats
représentent de moins en moins de gens
ils sont aussi vous allez c'est fatigués
des syndicalistes dans la zae plein de
gens qui sont mobilisés de conjoncturel
sur la réforme des retraites madame le
problème il est où c'est que le pouvoir
exécutif le président de la république
et le gouvernement si vous me permettez
l'expression
s'ils sont pris comme un manche où je
sais tu as dit que tu allais vraiment ça
c'est à dire que ça fait deux ans et
demi que cette réforme se désole t elle
était sur la table ça même été gelée
rappelé récemment la première des
réformes du programme d' emmanuel macron
alors page 13 du programme chaque
il est
pivot
il exactement marquer car s il ne
repousserait pas l'âge de départ a dit
ni la durée de 6 à sion train de vous
dire
c'est celle là c'est de dire on va faire
une retraite on va mettre tout le monde
dans un même régime universalité et
n'ont pas été capables un de l'expliquer
ils ont pas travailler parce que c'est
évidemment une réforme dans d'autres
pays ça s'est fait en cinq ans au
danemark notamment ça c'était une
réforme en suède ça s'est fait en cinq
ans cette réforme il regrette paradis
met tout le monde dans un même régime
pays regrette le niveau des pensions a
baissé pour certains et en disant que
tout soit hier il faut une part de
capitalisation qui existe déjà dans
d'autres pays y compris pour les
fonctionnaires ils ont été incapables
d'expliquer tout ça et en plus ils ont
rajouté une cerise sur le gâteau qui
évidemment est une cerise qui a fait
hurler beaucoup de français c'est qu' il
fallait travailler plus longtemps ok ça
c'est bien d'expliquer j'aimerais bien
tournés vers vous mais tenable pour
avoir ou un sentiment plus personnel sur
l'homme vous aviez interrogées on s'en
souvient françois hollande on savait que
tu as un président mal aimé il en
souffrait là on a un emmanuel macron qui
cristallise une détestation il ya
d'autres présidents qui ont été vraiment
chahuté mais est ce que là on n'est pas
dans une sorte de facture un peu
différente je pense que vous parliez de
dérive autoritaire quand jean-luc
mélenchon face à des journalistes dit je
suis l'état et
je suis passé je fais république c'est
la même chose il ya un climat comme ça
je pense qu emmanuel macron jean luc
mélenchon sont ravis de
s'auto-entretenir l'un l'autre cela
permet à tout le monde d'être bien
tranquille dans son camp et ça ne fait
pas gagner pour le coup le débat
démocratique je suis moi horrifié de
voir des gens qui se battent avec la
tête du président de la république au
bout d'une pique quel qu'il soit et je
trouve que c'est extraordinairement
choquant de même les crs
s'est fait dans l'histoire de france oui
ça c'est fait c'est ok attention vous
dis pas le mal de la révolution
moi ça me choque c'est des agrès sa
large de macron me choque aussi de la
même manière je pense que ça vous choque
de même manière manon enfin j'imagine la
différence c'est que
je suis je pense que quand on en arrive
à une telle situation c'est satisfaisant
pour personne et je me satisfais pas de
cette je vais je dire qu'elle était co
créé ont fait naître mais alors je pense
la différence nous de notre côté c'est
que justement est là où je suis d'accord
aussi avec votre analyse il ya un
problème avec la vème république c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça complète pour une
sixième république pour un autre juste
des choses qu'on ne saurait tarder avec
la tête du président et publico mais il
faut comprendre la détestation qui qui
qui a grandi en france dans toutes les
enquêtes d'opinion la détestation elle
devient personnelle quand bien même ça
quand bien même par donc mais c'est
choquant se balader avec ta tête du prix
je suis d'accord avec vous pour dire la
zone des caraïbes il faut dire que c'est
chaud quand j'essaie juste de comprendre
comment on en est arrivé là se dire ok
comment on sort de cette situation par
le rouge parce qu'on a des gens qui se
détestent
de l'huile sur le feu et que dents dans
le parti la france insoumise également
il ya une forme sans comment dire sans
alimenter les violences une condamnation
qui n'est pas toujours très audible
savez c'est souvent le reproche qu'on
nous fait et je trouve qu'il tourne
assez rapidement book parce que et je
vous l'aurais dit s'il ya plus besoin de
le clarifier n'ont jamais la violence
n'est un moyen ni une méthode en
démocratie pour se faire entendre je
crois qu'on peut pas être plus clair que
ça et qu'on ne sera jamais on ne sera
jamais l'alimentaire la violente madame
magasins avaient mais aujourd'hui si
vous voulez parler de violence il ya des
gens qui les subissent à cause des
violences policières à cause des
violences sociales et donc ces violences
là il faut les entendre et je ne dis pas
qu'il faut répondre par la violence
toujours vous savez on a toujours été
sur les piquets de grève auprès des
manifestants et on n'a jamais encouragé
la violence même mieux que ça quand on
se trimballe avec notre écharpe de
député on essaie quand c'est possible de
faire diminuer le niveau de tension
parce que on croit au dialogue
démocratique comme un outil pour
résoudre les tensions mais force est de
constater que de ce point de vue là ce
c'est pas emmanuel mâcon qui est du côté
de la démocratie en refusant d
y répondre par la violence je vous dis
juste qu'emmanuel mathis refuse
d'utiliser l'outil démocratique pour
écouter le jeu et que ça explique la
frustration qui entrèrent ce matin je
serai quoi se sentir vivre deux
séquences une séquence qui était
absolument pas contrôler qu'était la
séquence du gilet jaune où il n'y avait
pas de leaders où il n'y avait pas de
mot d'ordre où il y avait rien une
deuxième séquence qui est légal aux
séquences on ne peut plus classique de
conflit social autant que je sache la
deuxième séquence celle du conflit
social il n'y a pas eu plus de foyers
pas eu beaucoup de blessés y avaient
d'abord sur cette année images de
violence sur sept et demi
moore la même chose
la même chose j'ai pas la fin du super g
par comparaison que la séquence conflit
social est assez classique il ya
toujours des policiers avec des services
d'ordre des rares prestations dérape à
des provocations annoncé la première
séquence où elle me fait penser à celle
des gilet jaune à quelque chose qui a
été théorisée d'ailleurs par un
philosophe grec québec sq et analyser
comment les pays évolués alors vous
évoluez
à partir bon la monarchie les pouvoirs
autoritaires tout ça peut vous arriver à
la démocratie et quel est le régime qui
suit la démocratie c'est le look l'ocrha
si le clou grassi c'est quoi c'est comme
vous avez pas sur la base à général elle
agacée général où justement et une
révolte qui n'est absolument pas
canalisé qui ne débouchent sur rien qui
n'a pas de mot d'ordre qui n'a pas de
leader et c'est un peu ce que s'il est
sur le cul pendant six mois les
dernières démissions
dutronc va revenir ça c'est intéressant
solidarité sur la fortune et
les jus les jeunes ne se sont pas
emparés de cette mobilisation sur les
retraites qui aurait pu les concernent
et voilà celle de deux mouvements qui
sont restés de imperméable à l'eau dans
le marbre la manif on va quand même
s'intéresser quand même à cette journée
est ce que c'est un baroud d'honneur est
ce que c'est un regain de mobilisation
alors pour tout vous dire l'émission
enregistrée on ne pourra pas vous donner
des chiffres de la mobilisation doit
entendre les mots d'ordre et au même
moment on va entendre le secrétaire
d'état le monsieur retraites du
gouvernement qui présentait son texte
c'est signé ce sujet ahmed tazir
résa
slogan et chorégraphie au rythme des
tubes des années 80 11h30 ce matin la
manifestation parisienne contre la
réforme des retraites démarre
51e jour du mouvement et toujours la
mobilisation pour faire pression sur le
gouvernement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les syndicats fer de lance de la
contestation sont là la cgt son patron
philippe martinez qui jurent de tenir
jusqu'au retrait il ya eu il ya
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus de grévistes
vous parlez beaucoup des transports mais
dans l'ensemble des catégories de
salariés du pays que dans le public
comme dans le privé force ouvrière est
là aussi le message on entre dans une
phase nouvelle on va partir dans un
débat parlementaire eh bien on a devant
nous des semaines et des mois de
mobilisation sous des formes qu'on va
examiner pour faire en sorte de nous
faire comprendre de convaincre et j'ai
le sentiment à son âge nous dit que 60%
ou 61% de la population demande au
gouvernement de retirer cette réforme
j'ai l'impression qu'on se fait
comprendre que tout le monde a compris
qu'elle était le danger de cette réforme
au même moment le projet de loi de
réforme des retraites est présenté en
conseil des ministres en première ligne
la ministre de la santé qui détaille le
projet de réforme du système universel
de aujourd'hui il apparaît bien que
cette refondation d'un système de
retraite est un enjeu social est un
enjeu démocratique
les objectifs qui sont assignés à ce
nouveau système universel de retraite
sont l'équité entre tous les français et
entre les générations
la simplification et la lisibilité
les manifestations d'aujourd'hui sont
nationale à marseille quelques milliers
de manifestants ont battu le pavé à
nantes plusieurs milliers de personnes
ont bravé la pluie trois nouvelles
journées de mobilisation sont annoncées
pour la semaine prochaine et nous a
rejoint sur ce plateau raphaël legendre
bonsoir peut-être journaliste économique
à l'opinion et chroniqueur dans cette
émission peut-être juste quand vous
voyez vous avez manifesté ma nombre
l'idée c'est quoi ce soir ça y est on a
un projet de loi qui est au conseil des
ministres qui va arriver le 17 février à
l'assemblée c'est quoi jusqu'où vous
continuez jusqu'au retrait le mot
d'ordre il est très clair pour le coup
aussi
on écoute on entend tous ceux qui se
mobilisent sur le terrain de différentes
formes parce que au bout de près de 50
jours de grève forcément les gens sont
fatigués ils sont bruyants nole
utilisées se demander de quel côté le
pourrissement ce qui n'est pas du vôtre
à vouloir continuer vaille que vaille
alors qu'il ya quand même des lignes qui
bouge du côté du gouvernement les cas
liés à une conférence de financement
avec l'acm
si j'avais eu toute une série de régimes
spéciaux il ya des concessions qui
aurait été fait qui est prôné en soit
demain prenons-les dans l'ordre si je
vous dis je vais faire une conférence de
financement mais j'exclus d'ores et déjà
la possibilité d'augmenter les
cotisations sociales on parlait de
démocratie tout alors si vous voulez
faire une conférence sur le financement
où vous consultez alors laisser toutes
les portes ouvertes et toutes les
options ouvertes c'est pour ça que c'est
important de pas se faire le rêve est de
voir véritablement ce qui est mis sur la
table et force est de constater que
aujourd'hui le gouvernement n'est pas
prêt à revenir sur l'essentiel le coeur
de la réforme c'est ces fameux 14 % de
pib dédiée au financement des retraites
et c'est un enjeu important
moi ce que là on est dans une ère où on
serait manquer même temps c'est un peu
dur et parce que je ne pense pas vous
allez de nous le dire que vous allez
partager le texte le ça n'arrivera pas
cette année ça a été a été promulguée
donc voté à l'assemblée nationale même
promulguée avant d'être retiré la télé
j'espère qu'on arrivera vers les deux
bergers ont légiféré quand on a un
mouvement social même si il peut
s'essouffler mais qui dure aussi
longtemps c'est le plus longuement
social de pilotes qui est encore très
largement soutenu alors très largement
soutenu je sais pas puisque on n'a pas
les chiffres en tout cas comme vous
l'avez dit présent que l'amélioration
oui enfin les enquêtes de vous attendiez
à ce que cette scène s'est longtemps
c'est quand même impressionnant de
marseille voilà n'ont pas de raison en
tout cas nous moi je pense que ce qui
doit nous importer aujourd'hui
finalement c'est pas de savoir s'il y
avait plus de manifestants au moins deux
manifestants c'est pas ça le sujet
aujourd'hui pour le gouvernement je le
disais tout à l'heure il ya eu des
maladresses on n'a pas bien communiqué
on a peut être manqué de pédagogie
oh je le concède mais aussi parce qu'on
peut penser aujourd'hui non
ce que je dis vous y revenez à chaque
fois mais l'armée pour vous c'est juste
il faut mieux l'expliquer et les gens
vont être d'accord pensée et mettez
l'idée que les gens ont bien compris en
quoi consiste la réforme et qu'ils sont
contre ce que vous dites si on fait plus
de pédagogie jeu reprend exactement vos
mots oui alors les gens vont mieux
comprendre et donc être d'accord avec
votre demande c'est là ou alors je
comprends le raisonnement que j'avais
précédemment je disais si les jours
commencent et à des engagements de
campagne du candidat macron donc c'est
un engagement que nous mais toi s'enduit
en bas sur le départ à la retraite à 65
ans d'accord mais sur le projet de
réforme de retraite d'accord que c'était
bien dans le naufrage l'homme propose
aux candidats mais on pourra re vérifier
les mots exacts
mais pas de réforme des retraites et
c'était dans son projet donc que se
sortiraient pu vraiment tout simplement
que les gens travaillent plus longtemps
avant de partir à la retraite et des
pensions plus basse c'est simple et je
pense que cet horizon là c'est l'horizon
que veulent la majorité des français la
fesse gauche
ne seront ni la lettre d'accord c'est
une évidence la question c'est est-ce
que ça laisse des traces à face à face
qu combo on ne peut pas sortir même si
au fond on imagine peut-être l'issue est
que ce texte finira par être voté
sûrement amendé il y aura des déçus sur
ce on a l'impression que personne ne
sort gagnant de ce qui est en train de
se passer non mais c'est évident puisque
de toute manière le gouvernement a
conduit de réforme de façon tout à fait
chaotique et sans vraiment avoir préparé
son sujet de façon très amateur
finalement je suis désolé c'est pas les
maladresses ça commence à faire long
quand même puisque
déjà dit que sarkozy lui je dirai pas ce
que rendez vous compte dans quel pays y
aller un moment vous décidez de réformes
avant de savoir quel argent elle va vous
coûter cette réforme c'est à dire que là
on va voter si j'ai bien compris
normalement une réforme on va engager
une discussion sur la réforme et
parallèlement à ça on va convoquer une
conférence pour savoir comment va la
financer cette réforme sachant que cette
conférence sera sans doute difficile à
conduire parce qu'il y aura des
oppositions on ya personne ne va être
d'accord donc c'est quand même du
travail je dirais de gribouille 1 comme
on disait c'est de
gagner personne de sensé de les
syndicats finalement ils n'ont jamais
été en position de force dans cette
histoire ils ont mobilisé très peu de
gens dans les rues la preuve la plus
grande des manifestations qu'elles aient
lieu le 5 décembre elle a même pas
réunies cinq cent mille personnes je
vous rappelle qu'il ya dix ans des
millions de personnes 7 et 8 dans le
dans les rues donc ça s'est très vite
essoufflé c'est une poignée d'individus
dont les syndicats qui ont bloqué les
transports en commun et je vous invite à
aller d'ailleurs en province province
dans les transports urbains ça marchait
très bien il ya c'était vraiment ces
pays n'est pas bloqué donc il n'y a pas
de gagnant du côté des syndicats et le
gouvernement et le pouvoir exécutif n'a
pu que perdre des plumes dans cette
histoire parce que son autorité a été
contestée parce que il n'a pas préparé
son texte et parce que vis-à-vis d'un
certain électorat qui aujourd'hui
soutient la majorité présidentielle qui
était un électorat de droite ils vont
arriver au bout du compte en se disant
mais c'est très simple ça c'est une
réformette qui n'est pas qui ne tient
pas toutes ses promesses si il ya encore
des concessions qui sont fermés les
opposants non plus ne tire pas entre
guillemets les marrons du feu passe
quand on regarde s'il arrêtait
les faits mouvement social il y en a pas
a accepté que l'on fasse de la politique
pas pour tirer les marrons peu importe
l'expression mai et que oui mais sauf
que
l'objectif de manière concrète c'est que
le mouvement social puisse sortir
grandis puisse être écoutés et que le
projet de loi soit retirée et je veux
dire si toute l'opposition
s'écroule en matière de popularité je
m'en fous si jamais on arrive déjà à
gagner ça ça fait une différence alors
les gens qui se mobilisent ils se disent
ça marche on est écouté alors pour
l'instant ce projet de loi il n'est pas
retirée il est il est justement même
présenté en conseil des ministres rafael
vous avez vous avez pu le regarder ce
qu'on y voit plus clair qu'est ce qu'on
apprend on y voit un tout petit peu plus
clair alors si les français ont compris
la réforme des retraites moi je dis
chapeau nous les journalistes en tout
cas qui suivons ça depuis 24 mois
jusqu'ici on était dans le flou donc
jusqu'à aujourd'hui où on a enfin cette
étude d'impact et enfin quelques
chiffres sur la table car ça paraît
délirant mais cette réforme qui va
coûter des dizaines de milliards durant
la période de transition en tout cas et
aucun chiffre on en a quelques-uns
maintenant je vous en donne 3 pour
commencer le premier c'est une baisse
des inégalités que va entraîner cette
réforme dans la rémunération dans les
pensions des retraités une baisse de 28%
entre les 10% des retraités les plus
modestes et les 10% des retraités les
plus aisés c'est bien si je puis dire
avant la réforme c'est-à-dire dans le
système actuel cet écart serait de 7,1
après la réforme il ne sera plus que de
5,1 donc on réduit les inégalités avec
cette réforme comment réduire ces
inégalités par une hausse assez
importante des petites retraites en
réalité on a eu ces chiffres aussi
l'euro à aujourd'hui qui vont permettre
d'avoir le minimum aujourd'hui les 25 %
des retraités les plus modestes touche
510 euros par mois après la réforme ils
toucheront 660 euros on n'est pas 1000
euros parce que tout le monde n'est pas
à temps plein pour les temps partagé
voilà si on les met tous ensemble cette
moyenne sera 660 euros
c'est une augmentation de 25 % de la
retraite des 25% les plus modestes c'est
important pour les 25 % au-dessus ce
sera plus cinq et pour la moitié
supérieure des retraités c'est plus
important donc tout le monde en réalité
devrait gagner en retraite en tension
tout le monde sauf les plus riches les
trois cent mille français les plus
riches les 1% les fameux important dieu
verront leur pension baisser puisqu'il
ne cotiseront plus au delà de dix mille
euros par contre ils devront payer un
impôt de solidarité de 2 81% pour
financer dans l'instant rassurés les
réseaux donc aux arts dit est plutôt
effectivement rassurant je vous donne un
troisième exemple encore chez les plus
modestes un travailleur qui a cotisé
toute sa vie en étant au smic devrait
toucher aujourd'hui 1082 euros de
retraite compte qu'en 2025 et avec la
réforme de retraite par points ce sera
1147e hausse à l'antenne 6% donc on a
dans l'ensemble une mesure réforme qui
est plutôt redistributive alors il reste
encore quelques sujets à traiter qui
sont encore en négociation outre l'
équilibre financier en a parlé il y à
l'amélioration du minimum contributif
les faveurs les fameux pardon mille
euros qui vont se transformer en 85% du
smic et comme le smic va augmenter ses
1000 euros vont augmenter comment s'est
ainsi l'emploi des seniors aussi qui
devrait être facilité évidemment pour
travailler plus longtemps et puis
l'amélioration des critères de
pénibilité
aussi dans cette réforme met donc on a
plutôt dans l'ensemble une réforme de
gauche gérant quinquina érables et on a
du mal à comprendre que la france
insoumise se battre autant contre une
réforme qui privilégie en priorité les
plus modestes j'espère que le
gouvernement vous paiera un bon petit
chèque après cette promotion du costume
c'est tout ce qu'ils ont harper comme un
derby
du collectif allait regarder du côté du
collectif nos retraites qui désormais
laisse trop large et de très près les
cas qui sont présentés et qui a
notamment mis en exergue que sur les 28
cas qui sont présentés en réalité il y
en a que dix qui sont gagnants et 18 qui
souhaite
notamment parce que les pas appliquer le
bon bélier / malus si on veut bien
garder en tête et ce qui est dit très
clairement aussi dans l'étude d'impact
c'est que l'âge de départ à la retraite
donc pour toucher le fameux taux plein
ou l'équivalent 34 ans quand le départ
moyen est à 60 3 millions équivalent et
vous mettra pas la vie est un gros mâle
hui je crains partait avec des grosses
équipes
merci merci beaucoup d'être venus
débattre de ce sujet des retraites et de
ces mots présidentiels qui font qu'ils
font réagir vous restez avec nous
nathalie matte on va parler un peu de
vous à présent vahid est là et 17 025
interview que vous avez président
réalité pour m cp c'est une nouvelle
collection donc de grands entretiens
vous inaugurez donc avec deux visages
dans un décor noir va les voir deux
fauteuils c'est très très minimaliste et
très sobre mais c'est aussi assez
moderne on regarde ce que ça donne dans
le making of de ce travail tout de suite
[Musique]
les grands entretiens dès le cp vous
êtes plusieurs à les porter celle en
entretien et moi j'ai choisi de
m'intéresser à ceux qui s'engagent au
sens de l'engagement est donc là je
viens de finir l'interview de pierre
rené lemas qui a été secrétaire général
de l'elysée mais on a aussi car unis
forest qu'on connaît pour être assez
engagé il y aura rice qui sera là le
patron de charlie hebdo c'est quoi
l'engagement quand il est un poids aussi
forcé enfin bref on donne la parole à
ceux qui s'engagent ainsi à comprendre
ce que ça veut dire et quelle place à
pau on le vit l'intention de réalisation
cette émission c'était vraiment au coeur
du propos c'est vraiment dans l' écoute
et de créer un cadre intemporel voilà on
est vraiment dans les visages ont essayé
d'effacer complètement tout ce qui se
passait autour donc y'a aucun artifice
sous photo on la pensait un peu comme
une photo c'est le réalisateur du film
en france au dagobert très belle
collection alors il ya plein de
questions d'abord ce dispositif
j'imagine que vous en avez discuté avec
le réalisateur très intimiste ça veut
dire quoi l'obscurité ça favorise la
confidence est alors en fait le mois je
suis arrivé avec une idée et avec un
brief inverse de celui que vous venez de
voir c'est à dire que moi je me référais
aux studios américains des années 50
vous savez vous sais pas si vous vous
souvenez ces films où il danse est il
monté sur des échelles il montait sur un
banc il volé et se renouvelle un peu son
habitude il mesurerait des centaines de
mètres et avec c'était le sol et le et
le mur était de la même couleur et je
disais ou fait exactement la même chose
tout blanc avec deux cubes on s'assoit
et voilà donc là on est dans l' inverse
en fait mais ça fait exactement le même
résultat et c'est pas tant une histoire
d'intimité qu'une histoire d'une
interview alors oui on voit juste elle
est riche et de la question est
quelqu'un qui répond c'est tout alors
rice alain duhamel brigitte lahaye
pierre rené lemas caroline fourest
pourquoi ces cinq-là pierre rené lemas
au départ moi je voulais faire une
interview en fait je le point de départ
de tout ça c'était
d'abord de faire des interviews et comme
plus personne ne croit ni les
journalistes ni les politiques je
voulais montrer aux spectateurs que les
journalistes parfois avec du courage et
que les politiques ne manquez pas non
plus quand il fallait répondre et que
une interview c'était un truc c'était
une danser un tango c'est difficile et
quand c est comme ses bienfaits et bien
on obtient des réponses extraordinaire
et il se dit quelque chose je travaille
pas à l'office du tourisme des
politiques mais j'ai du respect pour eux
j'ai du respect en même temps
si renault
avec
lcp voulu ouvrir qu on fasse pas que des
politiques et donc on a transformé on a
clairement dit que la thématique c'était
l'engagement moi je voulais montrer de
l'engagement je pense qu'on est dans une
période dans un moment où il ya une
espèce de brouhaha moi en tout cas j'ai
du mal à penser et je suis pas plus
d'autre qu'une autre donc je pense que
je suis pas tout seul et il ya beaucoup
de bruit et il ya peu de choses claires
qui qui émergent et je pense que les
gens engagés disent des choses très
clair on n'est pas obligé d'être
d'accord avec eux pas du tout mais ils
disent des choses il porte un message
ils disent quelque chose et je pense qu
on a urgemment besoin d'entendre des
choses mais quelqu'un nous dire quelque
chose on va avoir d'ailleurs un premier
extrait regardez ce que ça donne
justement quand on entend mieux les
choses quand on se donne du temps c'est
un extrait avec avec crise c'est pas
possible d'oublier
cette fébrilité
qu'on ressent quand on voit quelqu'un
qui arrive devant vous avec une arme
voilà d'un seul coup tout est suspendu
le temps est suspendu et
et vous savez vous savez vous avait
basculé dans quelque chose
donc ça je les sens mais moins pas
seulement visuellement mais physiquement
très physique une mémoire physique des
choses c'est impossible pour moi
d'imaginer ce qui vous est arrivé même
si vous l'écrivez même si vous le
racontez dire vous le dites
il ya toujours quelque chose qui sera
irracontable on peut raconter beaucoup
de choses on peut décrire un coup de
choses mais au bout d'un moment vous
vous heurter un mur sorte de plafond de
verre vous ne pouvez pas aller au delà
de ceux d'un certain niveau
d'explications ou de transmission aux
autres voilà c'est là qu'a voir du temps
même pour dire l'indicible même pour
dire ce qu'on arrivera peut-être jamais
à comprendre c'est très important oui
reeti fait quelque chose de très fort
parce que lui il était engagé dans
charlie jeudi engagé parce que quand on
fait de la caricature quand on est un
jeune est ce qui fait de la caricature
c'est un choix très fort qu'on fait et
c'est un choix politique donc il était
engagé et quand les les frères couach
ils lui ont tiré dessus je vais poser la
question est-ce qu'ils ont changé la
nature de son engagement lui dit non il
dit que ça a renforcé son engagement
mais ça va et ça va changer quelque part
et et j'étais très très heureuse qui
viennent d'abord parce que moi il me
touche énormément et ensuite parce qu'il
nous il nous qu'on voit quoi ça lui est
arrivé à lui c'est son journal c'est à
sa personne que c'est arrivé c'est ni à
la vente gnagna la mienne et pourtant il
nous dit en me tirant dessus c'est à
vous qui s'adresse et il nous est le
fait de manière extrêmement apr
extrêmement sévère extrêmement exigeante
et c'est très bien que c'est une femme
l'accouchement aussi ces entretiens
j'adore comment on fait pour faire un
bon entretien complètement dehors de
l'actualité pour qu'il reste au fond on
écoute
c'est tout on écoute et on relance ses
longs d'écouté parce que pour pour
réussir à écouter quelqu'un il faut
renoncer à s'entendre soi même c'est à
dire que favre soit plus du tout des
gosses moins d'ego tél
dans ces solides ce mon cas plus besoin
de le mettre en avant vous voyez mais je
crois que oui ça s'apprend d'écouté et
ses salons et l'actualité ça vous manque
pas du tout non pas une seule ça une
pomme d'amour je vous le dis ce débat là
on vient d'avoir joué sanaa et des
personnes franchement je et moi je pense
qu à la télé ça doit être utile et tout
ça est et qu'on doit tous je pense que
ma nombre est quelqu'un de qu'il ya une
grande valeur je pense madame vous avez
certainement une grande valeur et salue
pas normal que deux femmes qui ont une
grande valeur n'arrive pas à se parler
pour nous faire avancer tous et donc ça
je sais je déteste de propos de de vieux
cons qui dit j'aime pas l'époque parce
qu'en plus jamais à l'époque mais il ya
un truc dans l'époque qui me précisément
qu après ses singles i soit c'est le
présent perpétuel cette espèce de le la
réflexion
on demande à tout le monde d'avoir un
avis sur tout immédiatement et cet avis
doit être noir blanc et et non en fait
non moi je peux juste pas penser comme
ça je pense que vous non plus mais on ne
peut pas chacun avoir un avis sur tout
comme ça parce qu'il faut le tweet et ou
parce qu'on me l'a demandé mais non en
fait non et c'est pour ça que les
décryptages sont importants c'est pour
ça que ce genre d'émission le temps il
est importante pour apporter justement
c'est selon c'est dommage mais ray quand
et de l'autre réinstaurer cette
conversation où on peut se parler et le
dialogue sont difficiles non c'est la
conversation tient dit discuter avec
quelqu'un qui n'est pas d'accord avec
vous oui et c'est pas grave quoi c'est
pas parce qu'on n'est pas d'accord quand
l'objet d'insultés quoi c'est ce n'est
pas grave au contraire c'est une chance
alors on va maintenant voir un deuxième
extrait on a commencé à en parler pierre
rené lemas oui c'est donc un haut
fonctionnaire oui que vous avez décidé
de mettre en lumière garder
commencé à avoir un bruit qui est le
président la république va parler dans
le petit studio de la rue de l'elysée
vous savez que l'elysée un petit studio
de télévision ou la presse et parfois
reçu voilà et donc on est allé avec
quelques amis
les amis du début du
du début du quinquennat françois
hollande le regarder à la télévision ce
doute et bien on avait compris quelque
chose quoi mais vous savez pas non c'est
pas même non non je savais pas et on
entendu le président hollande annoncé ça
et c'est vrai que ça a été un moment
étrange parce que on était on était on
avait dit des sentiments mélangés on
était un peu triste un peu furieux un
mélange des deux fois la crise qu'il n'y
avait pas furieux qu'ils ne voulaient
pas dit avant non très ce qu'il y ait un
furieux qu'ils y aillent points
à ce moment là d'ailleurs il n'est plus
secrétaire général de l'elysée avec des
amis du début de mandat unissent pour
regarder la télé donc c'est pierre rené
lemas il est assez peu connu du public
il a été secrétaire général de l'elysée
il est préfet il a été préfet en corse
entre autres il a été président de la
caisse des dépôts et consignations
aujourd'hui dirigeants des associations
il s'appelle france active et c'est un
grand serviteur de l'état ce qu'on
appelle ses grands serviteurs de l'état
qui a toujours travaillé plutôt dans la
discrétion d'ailleurs ils le
revendiquent ils le réclament d'autres
sont fait beaucoup plus connaître lui
avais pas envie de ça j'ai je me posais
une question avant j'ai tellement aimé
ça très beau je dise que ça rend heureux
de servir l'état mais mais juste pour ça
il faut regarder l'émission quoi la
manière dont il répond il me regarde en
fait oui c est bien évident mais je
trouve ça non mais je trouve ça
extraordinaire il parle aussi de la
charge que ça représente iwuy même
mouvement il a vu mourir des gens
proches il était ami du préfet erignac
son père a pris des balles dans le dos
en algérie pour son engagement politique
lui même a vu une bombe explosait dans
son bureau quand à son tour aider tes
préférences donc il sait ce que coûte
l'engagement vraiment très cher et il
répond que l'état n'est pas une vieille
idée déliquescente et voilà ça vaut le
coup quoi pour terminer alors laissé
pierre rené lemas et risques on pourra
voir dimanche prochain mais y aura aussi
précis plaît oui l'engagement et
brigitte lahaie c'est une évidence là
aussi un an je crois pas mais
on sent quand je vous le dire vous allez
me dire mais oui évidemment c'est une
jeune fille de 18 ans
de province famille plutôt bourgeoise
qui
dit au monde entier à sa classe sociale
à sa famille à son statut de femme et
bien moi ce par quoi je vais me réaliser
c'est la sexualité ben moi j'aurais été
capable de dire un truc pareil je vous
dis c'est hallucinant et par ailleurs
elle n'a jamais lâché cet engagement et
elle a été entendu cinq cent mille
auditeurs depuis toutes ces années
qu'elle a aidé à trouver une voie à
s'épanouir dans leur sexualité ou c'est
quand même pas rien quoi vous avez envie
de continuer en fer lors il se croit qu
il avait pas mal d'activités vous êtes
productrice oui j'ai la boite de prod
mais en fait j'avais m'étais dit je fais
180 ou après j'arrête je suis pas envie
de continuer c'est vrai oui j'ai ce que
j'ai adoré
en fait on a on a des gens dont je ne
peux pas refuser l'idée de les
interviewer qui nous ont dit oui donc je
veux écrire mais je veux je peux page de
regrets mais proto mais vous reviendrez
nos goûts du groupe
en tout cas bienvenue sur sur elle c'est
le risque vous restez avec nous je suis
sûr que le le sujet dont on va parler va
vous intéresser il s'agit évidemment de
la question du consentement le
consentement sexuel des mineurs alors
que dit la loi faute il a changé vous
souhaitez la changer nathalie et limaces
beaucoup de députés d'ailleurs sont
d'accord avec avec vous depuis depuis la
déflagration de la ferme à seneffe
explications hélène bonduelle le
consentement ou le récit de l'emprise
d'un écrivain de 50 ans sur une
adolescente de 13 ans nous sommes fin
décembre l'auteur est éditrice vanessa
spring aura publie son témoignage la
ferme at snef vient d'éclater c'était
important pour moi effectivement de
faire rentrer dans le champ littéraire
la voix d'une jeune fille qui avait été
victime
et parce que c'est une
voix qu'on entend jamais effectivement
littérature et à l'époque gabriel
matzneff se vante de ses écrits
pédophiles dont les médias marisa bête
gelé connu quand elle avait 15 ans la
haye la nana 20 ou 22 candidats solides
elle est toujours dans ma vie la ferme
at ce n'est relance le débat sur l'âge
du consentement sexuel d'ailleurs une
quarantaine de députés principalement
issus des rangs de la france insoumise
ont déposé une proposition de loi elle
prévoit de permettre une présomption
simple de la contrainte quand
l'agression sexuelle est pratiqué sur un
mineur de 13 ans et elle sera examinée
le 5 mars prochain un sujet déjà
défendue par les députés du groupe en
2017 il faut créer un seuil de
présomption de non consentement et le
porter à l'âge de la majorité sexuelle
15 ans pour qu'il y est un âge en
dessous duquel le discernement et le
consentement ne puisse être invoquée
nous sommes en plein débat au parlement
autour de la loi contre les violences
sexuelles et sexistes
le gouvernement évoque déjà l'âge du
consentement sexuel la question
effectivement qui est aujourd'hui posée
c'est celle de l'établissement d'un
seuil en deçà duquel le consentement du
mineur est présumé ne pas exister
beaucoup de pays européens ont établi
cette règle avec des seuils d'âge
différent qui varient
globalement entre 13 et 15 ans nous
sommes nous sommes en train de réfléchir
à un meilleur âge possible évidemment
nous le ferons avec l'ensemble des
parties prenantes mais la loi a
finalement été voté sans âge de
consentement retour au point de départ
en attendant le gouvernement lui propose
une évaluation de la loi schiappa deux
ans après sa mise en oeuvre elle
commencera lundi et devrait durer jusque
fin avril bonsoir pascal que c'était
bien bienvenue sur ce plateau vous êtes
avocat vous présidez l'association coup
de pouce protection de l'enfant vous
allez nous expliquer ce que vous voulez
précisément faire sur ce fameux l'âge de
consentement c'est très compliqué hein
juridiquement mais j'aurai la bamboo
vous faire réagir vous l'avez lu le
livre de vanessa spring aura voulait
bien entendu mais je suis en train de le
lire j'ai pas terminé encore mais je je
veux revenir un petit peu en arrière
parce que au delà de cette affaire
il n'y a pas si longtemps encore il y
avait à dell à nesle et puis moi quand
je me suis saisi de cette question vous
venez de parler d'engagement mais ça une
histoire aussi pour moi je venais
d'arriver à l'assemblée nationale donc
en juin 2017 et en septembre j'ai reçu
un message un cri du père de la petite
sarah
c'est la sphère de pontoise voilà il se
trouve que cette famille habite la
circonscription sur laquelle je suis élu
je les ai rencontrés j'ai rencontré
sarah j'ai rencontré son avocate et je
suis une femme je suis une mère j'ai
quatre enfants je suis une élue et il
était évident que je ne pouvais pas
laisser les choses en l'état et pour moi
il est évident qu'il faut absolument
réformer la loi et qu'il faut faire en
sorte que plus jamais le consentement
d'un enfant d'un mineur à l'acte sexuel
ne puisse être interrogé alors justement
qu'est ce qu'on doit faire
m à votre avis déjà est il vrai qu'il
n'existe pas aujourd'hui clairement
d'âge de conte du consentement pour la
minorité sexuelle c'est dans la loi
aujourd'hui c'est tout à fait vrai
contrairement à ce que les pouvoirs
publics ont pu faire croire après le
vote de la loi tient pas
le nouvel article qui a été introduit
renvoie aux capacités de discernement de
l'enfant c'est à dire qu'on continue à
examiner alors c'est plus le
consentement c'est le discernement mais
c'est exactement la même chose
c'est-à-dire qu'on continue à examiner
au cas par cas si l'enfant a pu
consentir ou pas et ce qui est pour nous
une aberration totale c'est que c'est un
régime qui est donc adoptée pour les
mineurs de moins de 15 ans sans qu'il y
ait de distinctions particulières c'est
à dire que cette question sur le
discernement à devrait se poser d'après
la loi chien pas même pour des enfants
de 3 2 6 ans de 8 ans ce qui est juste
un défi au bon sens lorsque vous
réclamez très clairement c'est qu'on est
à un âge 15 ans pourquoi pas 15 ans
c'est ce que vous défendez peut-être
moins je vais même deux propositions
pour que pour quoi pour qu'on se dise on
arrête jusqu'à 15 ans j'essaye de
schématiser de se poser la question du
du consentement dans le cadre des
agressions ou des atteintes 5 c'est ce
que marlène schiappa avait annoncé elle
avait dit dans un quotidien que il ne
devait plus posé la question du
consentement d'un enfant alors il y
avait une discussion sur l'âge c'est ce
qu'on a entendu aussi dans votre
reportage de madame belloubet à
l'expliquer effectivement que d'autres
pays avaient adopté cet âge de non
consentement et on se rende compte
effectivement quand on fait le
comparatif que la france est extrêmement
en retard le l'angleterre à une
présomption de non consentement depuis
1956 c'est à dire que l'âge 1 13 ans ça
veut dire que ça fait 60 ans qu'ils ont
résolu la question
nous on s'entête et j'ai été étonné au
moment des débats à l'assemblée
nationale de constater que ces
comparatifs là avec les autres droits
avaient été un peu passé sous silence
c'est à dire que on invoque des
arguments qui d'après moi sont
fallacieux sur le non respect de la
présomption d'innocence sans même
s'apercevoir que ces pays-là la belgique
l'angleterre par exemple qui sont soumis
eux aussi au respect de la présomption
d'innocence ont un âge de noëlla il se
passe quelque chose et une prise de
conscience collective les esprits
moralité très clairement que son livre
n'aurait pas eu le même impact
médiatique et encore cinq ans qu'est ce
que vous vous proposez pour qu'on puisse
au fond vraiment se dire on est en face
de pédocriminalité et donc arrêtons de
se poser la question de ce consentement
voulez vous le passez à quel âge à 15 à
13 moi je veux que de façon extrêmement
clair maintenant on rappelle la force de
l'interdît ça c'est la première chose il
faut que l'on reconnaisse la victime
comme étant une victime et il faut que
l'on condamne son agresseur une fois
qu'on a dit ça comment on s'y prend à
l'occasion de l'examen du texte de
marlène schiappa donc la loi de 2018 moi
j'avais fait deux propositions par voie
d'amendement de seuils d'âge un premier
seuil d'âge à 13 ans où effectivement je
proposais une présomption irréfragable
alors tous les arguments qui monte
verità osé on ne peut pas la démonter
absolument parce que je considère pas ce
qu on dit mineure de 13 ans donc on
imagine un enfant de 13 ans mais un
mineur de 13 ans c'est quoi ça peut être
un enfant de deux ans ça peut être un
enfant de cinq ans a peut être un bébé
ça peut être un petit garçon de neuf ans
qu'on emmène dans un local poubelle en
demandant de faire une fellation est ce
qu'on peut penser un instant qu'il a été
volontaire pour le faire non donc pour
moi il y avait une présomption
irréfragable pour un mineur de 13 ans et
une présomption simple pour un mineur de
15 ans par ce que j'entends en effet que
entre 13 et 15 ans une jeune fille qui
peut être fort mais on peut
éventuellement ça peut peut-être porter
à confusion et dans ce cas là c'est une
présomption simple vous allez reproposer
ça alors aujourd'hui à la france d'un
sommet la france instance 1 les
républicains veulent aller à 15 ans la
france insoumise ont effectivement
déposent une proposition de loi qui sera
examiné à l'assemblée nationale la le le
5 dont qui pose une présomption de
contrainte et qui la fixe à 13 ans je
rappelle que vous êtes modem vous
pourriez voter ce texte je vais voter ce
texte bien évidemment et dans une
tribune que j'ai fait paraître dans le
parisien ce week-end j'appelle
évidemment mes collègues sur tous les
bancs de cette assemblée a voté ce texte
est à faire bouger les lignes peut-être
à l'amendé et pourquoi pas et je je je
verrai moi même si avec mon groupe nous
décidons de remettre aux débats cet
amendement sur l'ir et frag habilité
pardon mais bien sûr il n'y a pas ce
n'est pas un combat trans partisan c'est
une question de société et c'est surtout
la question c'est comment aujourd'hui en
france on veut protéger nos enfants des
passes avec les vaches
moi je
j'ai lu un papier très juste
malheureusement je cherche un nom du
journaliste duel remarquable qui disait
qui expliquait qu elle quand elle était
jeune fille elle était tombée amoureuse
d'un ami de ses parents et que l avais
dragué quoi enfin elles doivent avoir 11
ou 12 ans et que cet homme a un moment
où elle se rapprocher un peu trop avait
pris sa main et l'a remise à sa place et
lui a dit non je pense que la personne
importante dans ce cas là c'est l'adulte
et pas l'enfant et il me semble encore
qu'on est dans un pays où il est
interdit de coucher avec oui c'est bien
des mineurs gars que jamais il faut
combler la force de l'après oui mais
pourquoi il faut il rappeler la force de
quelque chose qui est interdit c'est
interdit c'est interdit c'est pas
interdit un peu ou interdits moyennement
cet interdit cet interdit fin c'est lé
mac
malgré l'interdît la justice n'est
jamais passé mais parce que personne ne
la saisit et puis c'est interdit en fait
un peu parce que avec ces discussions
sur le consentement on qualifie
d'atteinte sexuelle et on renvoie devant
tribunal correctionnel ça veut dire que
les affaires au lieu d'être jugé par une
cour d'assises on demande un tribunal
correctionnel de faire en deux heures ce
qu'une cour d'assises mettrait trois
jours à faire donc c'est en fait c'est
interdit un peu c'est à dire que c'est
interdit mais ont requalifié en attente
sexuelle c'est en fait c'est pour ça que
vient de l'unité au final moi j'entends
très bien et je sais ce que vous dites
là dessus sur les tribunaux d'assises et
je comprends très bien que c'est le sens
de votre démarche mais c'est pas avec
des jeux en tous cas je vous pose la
question est-ce que c'est avec des
arrangements techniques et juridiques qu
on faire avancer une société non c'est
interdit de toucher un enfant même s'il
est d'accord et même s'il est très jolie
est scellé et c'est vrai il est à
l'origine même de
près dans ce drame mais les chiffres et
notamment ceux de l'inceste c'est le
maintien dit oui il est bien sûr
malheureusement dans les familles c'est
une sordide réalité là aussi si tu peux
rajouter un point il ya quelque chose
qui me surprend moi
niveau qu'est dans notre reportage le la
commission qui doit examiner
l'application de la loi schiappa nous
nous sommes réunis entre associations de
protection de l'enfance nous sommes
trente associations à s'être réunis au
sein d'un collectif qui s'appelle le
collectif pour l'enfant ce qui a pour
but de faire reconnaître l'incapacité de
l'enfant à consentir nous avons demandé
à être entendu par monsieur adrien
taquet depuis plusieurs mois il se
trouve que apparemment 30 associations
de protection de l'enfance qui
l'alertent sur un sujet préoccupant ça
n'a pas été digne d'intérêt puisqu'on
n'a pas eu de réponse moi je suis étonné
qu'on ignore à ce point l'avis de
professionnels de terrain les
associations de proscription de non
protection de l'enfance sont des
psychologues des avocats des
professionnels qui voient tous les jours
les ravages de notre système actuel
auquel il demande d'être entendu il va
d'ailleurs s'exprimer en début de
semaine sur le sujet il faut oser là
aussi sur un sujet comme ça concertée
j'imagine que oui et concertée il faut
évidemment écouter les professionnels et
puis il faut avoir en ligne de mire que
ce qu'il faut avant tout c'est toujours
veillé à protéger nos enfants merci
beaucoup merci d'être venu sur le
plateau de lcp évoqué ces sujets merci
mathema merci mon dieu quand vous voulez
je rappelle vos entretiens et ça
commence dès dimanche c'est une très
belle collection deux premiers
entretiens pierre rené lemas et reset à
23h07 avec maïtena biraben et s'est
invité sur la chaîne parlementaire celle
week end profitez bien
[Musique]